welcome back to safety blitz we want to
lock in on these teams who are winless
right now only been a couple games for
the 0 and 2 teams those who have not got
a win yet
how likely that they could make the
playoffs if we had to choose a team or
two out of this group atlanta detroit
indy jacksonville minnesota the new york
giants and the new york jets the two new
york teams the final two who might make
the playoffs out of that group who is
the reason for optimism in that squad
there rod
i think i would say the minnesota
vikings first and foremost um you know
they had a fumble in the first game and
missed the chip shot phil go in the
second game they should easily be 2-0
they got veteran quarterback good wide
receivers
experience head coach and i think that
defense will continue to get better they
have to find a kicker that's something
that's plagued in the last few years and
i would also say possibly the
indianapolis coats once again you heard
me earlier talk about their offensive
line the experience that they have at a
lot of different positions and really
carson wentz is the guy that's holding
him back you know you look at how how
long he holds on to the ball they have a
great running game if frank wright if he
just runs the football
you know and his defense should come
around they got some they got some
really good players on the defensive
side of the ball they're just not
getting it done
i'm right there with you on minnesota
indy's another good one because indy i
mean really should have beaten the ramps
and we were so high on the rams leaving
that bears game in week one which was
our sunday night opener so you got to
feel good about the team that the rams
are and indy went toe to toe with them
all the way to the end owen two i got it
but a healthy wince the way they played
that offensive line if wins could start
returning to some of that best philly
form that we saw got to think that
there's some hope there and if you look
at cousins cousins really played great
yesterday dalvin cook had a big day out
of the backfield they have good wide
receivers osborne thielen justin
jefferson all of them had big games as
well so there is weaponry on that
offense i i'm a believer in both those
two that you just picked that maybe the
next one that would be on my list i
don't know if i'm willing to go playoffs
but i at least think that there's some
reason to believe that they could be
heading in a better direction than new
york giants what are you seeing from the
new york giants now that saquon barkley
comes back uh year two now with the new
quarterback what are you seeing what do
you believe in when it comes to daniel
jones and the giants
well i'm just i look at the cowboys
first and foremost and i'm like okay
watching the cowboys and watching the
giants i'm a lot more impressed with the
cowboys i know they've had some injuries
but i like what they're doing on the
defensive side of the ball um you know
obviously dak is is the guy on the
offense but yeah man um you talking
about menace you talking about minnesota
oh no you're talking about the giants
the giants i'm not a big believer in the
giants i think they go as daniel jones
goes and to me he's just still kind of
inconsistent when he walks up to the
line of scrimmage i don't know if this
this is the guy that i feel
the utmost confidence in or does he even
project a level of confidence he's just
so up and down i like the kid i think he
wants to be good i like the way he
carries himself he's a good athlete but
i'm just as a team i'm just like unsure
about the giants at this point in time
yeah they did everything in their power
to blow that thursday night game and
wound up doing it that's why they're 0-2
and on our list here let's get to the
afc north the question marks in that
division it's a whole bunch of
one-and-one teams as you look around the
ravens 1-1 the bengals now 1-1 the
steelers blow it this week now they're
one-and-one there's one other team the
browns they lose come back get a win
they're all one and one there's some
mystery so who ended up winning this
division now who who ends up taking the
north who's the king of the north as
we're through a couple weeks what have
you seen from that conference in
particular
all right i mean i don't know which team
i would okay i'm gonna start with the
cleveland browns and for me the biggest
thing that i see from the cleveland
browns this revamped defense it's gonna
take time you don't see the consistent
pressure that you want from clowny
you know you don't you don't the
linebackers the secondary it just takes
time for these guys to really gel
together they haven't played a lot
together and communication is huge so i
think
you know in the next three to four weeks
you're gonna really start to see the
browns take shape you're gonna see these
guys that they can stay healthy the
communication and the trust and faith
because you have to have trust and faith
you know in one another if you're going
to play great defense and a lot of times
i don't see those guys trusting that hey
i'm going to be in this gap you stay in
your gap i see guys cheating looking you
know doing things that they're not
supposed to do and a lot of that comes
from the defensive coordinator joe wood
so he has to make sure that he instills
confidence in these guys and clowny and
you know they got to get after the
quarterback man they're getting paid a
lot of money i was garrett
i was garrett as well
a big year
big year last year even though he was
coming off covid and kova really was
tough for him to get it took him a while
maybe a month two months to really come
off the back end to get back to his best
form after all of that a season to go
but you got to think as he continues to
elevate his game that it would be a big
finish to the year really has to be a
big finish to the year
i'm going through my head who do i think
wins this division right now and frankly
i really don't know the steelers and ben
roethlisberger i just was very
underwhelmed by ben roethlisberger
yesterday he was taking some big shots
back there he's holding the ball and
over his career he's held the ball a
long time and he does these huge pump
fakes right that moves the whole defense
he'll go home and you're like how did he
still hang on to the ball and it'll turn
and then he'll complete one back that
way so he has that ability to do it but
he used to be athletic too so he could
do this big pump fake but then he could
run and move and create a second spot to
throw from he really has a hard time
doing that now he's kind of stagnant
back there and he's just taking these
big hits and creating more pressure
lofting up
he's old what are you seeing from
roethlisberger back there right
i see a i see a guy that has doesn't
have a lot of trust and faith in his
offensive line man i played against the
sealers for 15 years i've covered them
the last 13 years and they've always had
a good offensive line and i don't know
what happened yeah you go out and you
pay t.j 28 million dollars a year but
you can't forget about protecting your
quarterback and that's what it seems
like they've forgotten to do to pay some
offensive linemen you got naji harris
naji harris is the perfect running back
for this system he's big he's powerful
he can catch out of the backfield he
runs like and i don't know if this is
before your time but he runs like roger
craig do you remember roger craig the
old legend from san francisco
high knees i wish i did but i can't lie
i don't
i don't remember
yeah just plays with a lot of energy
education though
yeah right they have the perfect bat
they got the tight end i like the fryer
fryer fryer
is that how you say his name but i like
the young tight end they got weapons
it's just that offensive line and he's
he's not as athletic as he used to be so
now he's having problems you talk about
that huh well he used to be able to come
back real quick and just sling the ball
he can't do that anymore he takes that
pump fake and it takes him a lot longer
to get wound up to throw that ball and
release it and juju smith shuster
to me
every you know everybody tries to make
him out like he's an elite slot player
and to me it's just i'm waiting for that
eliteness i'm waiting for him to really
take that next step and to me he just
he's just a solid player he's not great
he's not special and i want to see him
get to the point where he's dominating
people
and i i just don't see that man
yeah no i don't either they're going
back to that whole quick passing game
thing where that's like becomes their
run game where you know they don't trust
big ben to push it down the field like
he used to so instead they just snap the
ball and just flip it out to these
receivers and it becomes that run game
element deante johnson claypool juju
smith smith schuster that's that sort of
has become the strategy for this offense
but when i see big ben try to really put
some mustard on one of these deep balls
or push it down the field to claypool it
just has this sort of lollipop element
to it doesn't get there on a line or a
zip he doesn't really give him a chance
to go up and get it or put it deep
enough to where he can go run underneath
of it it just kind of floats up there in
the air and that's why i think that
they're trying to go to this quick game
just to make sure that they're getting
these playmakers the ball enough to go
try to win a game and nadia harris back
there who's the first round pick in the
backfield
out of alabama
he has a little of le'veon bell in him
when he was in pittsburgh he could catch
the ball out of the backfield he ran in
a nice touchdown on a catch this weekend
for pittsburgh but he also misses a ton
in pass protection and while this
offensive line's having their own
struggles it's dangerous having a rookie
running back back there trying to clean
up the best that it still is
yeah and but to me once again you know
that's that's on the coaching staff to
make sure that the offensive line and
you know the
the quarterback ben i mean he's a
veteran he's been back there for however
long 15 17 years or whatever he's played
all he has to do is say naji you take
this guy that's blitzing watch the mike
linebacker you take him or if the
defensive end drops you got the safety
that's coming like just simple
communication and naji harris is a tough
smart kid and we know that he's been
coached by saving so he's seen like pro
offenses and stuff like this this stuff
ain't new to him he can play get him the
ball block and reestablish your identity
if you possibly can but thinking that
you're going to go far in this afc north
with big ben dropping back 30 40 times
every single game passing the ball is
not going to happen especially with the
injuries that you incurred on the
defensive side of the ball who knows how
long tj watts going to be out
our final question here for third and
short a segment that's been third and
long this week third and short from time
to time we actually do play to the name
let's get to this final one we have all
these injured quarterbacks rodney you
know just everywhere you look around the
league wins tyrod taylor tua andy dalton
big ben has a peck injury which i think
i know the exact play that that came on
he got hit right was he was right here
and you could just see he kind of got up
slowly right after it all these injured
quarterbacks does cam newton now
re-enter into the fold with any of these
situations does cam newton play this
year overall what do you think
well what
i don't think so i think with all the
injuries that have happened if cam
newton was if someone was truly
interested in cam they would have
contacted him and i think he would have
been in for
for some type of workout or something
like that i i don't think cam newton is
the is the answer for say the pittsburgh
steelers or you know indianapolis colts
i mean think about it when he got cut
from the patriots he was still trying to
learn the offense from the patriots now
you bring him in and now you're going to
put him with the coats or pittsburgh or
some team like that trying to figure out
another system i just think it's it's
it's too much to go into that's why you
have backup quarterbacks already on the
roster and that's something that he's
gonna have to deal with
i don't think i believe it either i just
don't see it i don't see him ending up
on a team this year it's kind of crazy
to say that think about all his time
with caroline and taking him to the
super bowl i just think it might be a
wrap we'll find out long season ahead
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports